alex how are you man
hey pomp thanks for having me i'm
excited to be here of course let's uh
let's start just real quick with remind
everyone what the human rights
foundation's kind of mandate is and how
you spend your time every day
sure
so i joined the human rights foundation
in in 2007
uh we
exist to help people who live under
authoritarian regimes around the world
who don't have some of the same rights
and liberties that we might have in a
society like the united states or
germany or japan
the the kind of cold reality is that 4.3
billion people around the world live
under some kind of authoritarian regime
maybe that's in cuba maybe that's in
iran maybe that's in china maybe that's
in russia
you know and they don't have any sort of
semblance or
uh any sort of real way to like push for
their own rights or to ask for reform
uh obviously in the united states
there's been lobby groups and kind of
corporations and different people kind
of pushing back for example against um
undue regulations on let's say bitcoin
and cryptocurrency
that's not going to happen in china or
russia right there's no sort of like
reform mechanism for so many people
around the world so for them
you know the open source code
is is really their main tool to defend
themselves right and when you talk about
code i think there's two two useful um
uh types to think about uh over the last
20 years one would be encryption right
that that allows us to transact
privately in terms of our communications
um and one would be bitcoin right so
with bitcoin
what i've discovered through all my work
at the human rights foundation over the
last five years just kind of surveying
activists around the world is that
their money's broken it's not as good as
ours their currency gets debased it
collapses their bank accounts get frozen
they're isolated they're behind
sanctions they're behind embargoes they
have broken infrastructure
um and and yet bitcoin is there for them
right and bitcoin allows them to save to
send uh to pay uh and to and to interact
with the world
you know at a time when there's just so
many bridges so much surveillance
and so much nonsense so you know i think
it's probably the most powerful tool for
human rights in the world today
when you think about a situation like
afghanistan let's maybe start there um
obviously we saw the decision and we uh
covered it we actually had a funeral for
western union on the show uh because
it's pretty much over for them but
western union abandons the country of
afghanistan it completely cuts off any
sort of technological support or service
there
talk about what the impact of that is
maybe first right so when the legacy
systems
fail to provide service or the people of
a country don't have access to financial
services like what is the negative
impact that you guys see in these
situations sure well look a country like
afghanistan four percent of the gdp
comes from remittances so we're talking
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
um
and that's that's really important for
for a country that doesn't have like
thick market margins right you know
they're like really struggling to get by
and then all of a sudden you know
an external decision
made by basically american
power
uh
shutters western union right it shudders
moneygram it shutters some of the main
ways that afghan families abroad get
money back back to back home
um i mean that's an absolutely brutal
situation because at the same time the
central bank has been closed off in
afghanistan right so
the flow of dollars that props up the
afghani the local currency has also been
closed so not only do you have the
the banks getting cut off from their
normal
source of funds but you have private
individuals and families get cut you
know getting cut off from their their
source of funds and you know what's
going to happen is quite predictable i
mean the currency uh is going to get
weaker it's going to devalue prices are
going to go up for goods you're already
seeing this um
just this summer the afghani has gone
from something like 70 something to per
dollar and it went all the way up to
near 100 per dollar it's kind of
floating around but but we kind of know
where this goes
and
whether it's you know whether you want
to blame this on the united states
government and pulling out too fast or
you want to blame it on them for being
there in the first place or you want to
blame it on the taliban at the end of
the day it doesn't really matter because
the the average person is suffering like
they're the ones that are going to pay
the price so regardless of like how we
want to argue about who's it who's at
fault here
the average person is going to suffer
because their currency is going to
collapse and their banking system has
frozen up like if you basically if you
didn't get your money out before kabul
fell you don't have your money like like
it's it's gone like there's no way to
withdraw that from the bank right
so even the people who made it out who
didn't want to live under the taliban if
they didn't you know plan ahead and get
the money out they had to leave without
their wealth in savings right so bitcoin
fixes this quite literally you know i'm
i'm this week i'm profiling a remarkable
afghan uh entrepreneur named roya mabub
for an essay i'm doing and she was
telling me that uh
i mean she's a bitcoin og i mean she's
been using bitcoin there since 2013. i
mean when she first learned about
bitcoin it was ten dollars for a bitcoin
when she bought her first bitcoin it was
100 bucks so she's been in it for a long
time and she's she's seen kind of
this this this technology appreciate and
she's seen fiat money depreciate she
means she really really deeply
understands how powerful this is as a as
a tool of
freedom
and she went to uh kabul earlier this
year and she tried to convince her
parents to buy some bitcoin
and you know she regrets not being
persuasive enough because they ended up
not being not buying bitcoin and then
they had to flee and and they weren't
able to bring their savings with them
right but those who were uh thinking
ahead in this way
um seeing around the curve that they
were able to
to help themselves and she has amazing
stories of you know paying women way
back then even in 2013-14
in bitcoin because in afghanistan like
uh you know women are sort of either not
allowed to or discouraged from having a
bank account and the their fathers and
brothers and uncles often will just take
their cash if they have it but they all
have cell phones or a lot of the young
folks have cell phones and royal would
pay them in bitcoin and then that was
like freedom to them right no one could
take that from them and they had you
know control and sovereignty right which
is a very powerful concept and really
like you know she's like a cypherpunk
basically she just doesn't know it right
at the time
uh she's fighting for she's using
technology to achieve what what politics
and what society won't give her right
and you know she tells me the story of
one of these women that you paid in
bitcoin who had to flee because of like
basically attacks on on her and her
family
you know
not the government necessarily but
not even the taliban but like local kind
of conservative religious elements
didn't really like the fact that this
woman was working
uh was in technology so so she had to
leave but she was able to bring her
bitcoin seed with her on this perilous
route through iran through turkey i mean
we're talking hundreds of thousands of
afghans have fled have become refugees
and have gone to europe over this route
right and there's all kinds of thieves
and brokers and her boat sank in the
mediterranean and all the stuff and
really you end up in europe if you make
it with with nothing with just the
clothes on your back but she was able to
bring her seed
and she was able to have that big two
and a half bitcoin she had and she ended
up selling some of it in 2017 when she
finally got to germany to start a new
life and i just think that story is so
powerful and illustrates
precisely why this technology is so
important
when you think about uh those two
stories the parents who know nothing
about bitcoin did not buy bitcoin before
this occurred uh and then the folks who
were very into bitcoin uh before it
seems like uh one group is prepared one
group is not what do we do for the
unprepared group today right so we've
got a bunch of people hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people who
did not know about bitcoin or weren't
interested in bitcoin uh kabul falls
obviously there's mass chaos and
uncertainty both in that city and across
the country
there is this very serious i think
largely accepted idea
that the currency now is in big trouble
and there's also a lot of censorship
and there's also a lot of seizureship
that's happening with people's savings
or wealth so it almost feels like
the best situation would have been to be
prepared for this if you're not
what can we do now like how do you how
does the human rights foundation think
about like what can be done today for
those that are in this situation uh in
afghanistan whether it's bitcoin related
or not
well um
look roya uh doesn't want to give up so
she's going to
look she could sit from outside and
criticize the taliban obviously you know
a disaster for women's rights or she
could she could try to make a difference
right so she's going to try and
essentially negotiate to keep her
programs running
uh she thinks it's it's it's possible
and she's going to keep educating women
in afghanistan about bitcoin i i think
that that's her narrow um
goal and that's what she's going to do
more broadly that's what we all can do i
mean it's just a matter of time and i
think it's a confluence of confidence
in us like as users of bitcoin you know
when roya first started using it in 2013
yeah it was great that bitcoin went from
ten dollars to a thousand dollars in a
year think about that went from ten
dollars to a thousand dollars in a year
and she felt invincible but guess what
happened at the end of 2013 it collapsed
okay and she had to offer she had to go
back to all those women that she had
paid in bitcoin and i just think this is
a mark of her character but she offered
to pay them uh back in fiat at the you
know at the amount that that they were
paid in fiat terms so she ended up
losing a lot of value at that time
because of that bitcoin crash um but the
the the idea of being your own bank just
kind of burned in her mind like she
couldn't even even after this crazy
crash she couldn't
you know she couldn't forget it she
couldn't forget this like principle this
idea
so we live in a day now where bitcoin's
way less risky i mean we're not going to
have a mount gox situation uh
it's just so much more mainstream so
much more acceptable uh you know so we
have the confidence as users that maybe
they didn't have five six seven years
ago
um and you also have the tools man like
i mean i would encourage people
listening to download something called
the moon wallet m-u-u-n it's on ios on
your iphone it's on android you can open
this thing up you don't have to write
down a bunch of seed words when you open
it it's very intuitive you just
literally download it and you can just
start receiving lightning or bitcoin
right away
so i think the apps and the ux and and
the confidence in ourselves make make it
a lot easier to to talk to family and
friends and then and then it's about the
stories i mean now her parents know you
know now they know right so oftentimes
it comes too late but if you can if you
can explain what's happened in different
countries whether it be venezuela or
palestine or cuba uh or even china uh or
or you know of course afghanistan
if you can explain how how money
has has been used against the people
has collapsed uh has been seized has
been confiscated then then it helps so i
think we're in a better position to do
more bitcoin education today um but i
think it starts with you and it starts
with your family and it starts with the
people that you care about i mean
there is a great opportunity to educate
people about bitcoin today right now
we're still at 200 million or so users
okay that's we're at about two percent
of the world population so we're at
about 1997 for the internet if you want
to compare bitcoin adoption to the
internet we're at about 1997. so we're
still at the end of the dial up era
think about what happened in the 10
years from 97 to 2007 we went from you
know your little machine making noises
trying to connect to the internet to the
iphone so
you're an early user if you're listening
to this and
you will be very grateful that you
invested at least your time and and in
learning about bitcoin and educating
your family and friends of people you
care about in 10 years that's going to
look like a really smart decision so i
think that's what we need to focus on
right now
one of the fascinating parts about
afghanistan right now is obviously
everyone is very focused rightfully so
on the individuals that uh are suffering
in that country that are um kind of at
the hands of a very very bad group of
people um and there's a lot of
uncertainty there's a lot of chaos
there's a lot of moving parts and and i
think over the next couple of weeks or
months we'll figure out kind of more of
what's going on and how people can help
but the country itself has also been a
victim of this censorship that exists
inside of the legacy financial system my
understanding is that they have a bunch
of gold
that is the country's gold right so the
actual nation state itself uh has gold
reserves but they are held outside of
the country i think here in the u.s with
the new york fed or something like that
and that has now been frozen so all of
the assets being frozen how do you think
about that like it's so weird where the
individual citizens are obviously being
affected but also the nation-state level
is also being affected by something very
similar and probably could have
benefited from having bitcoin themselves
yeah so we discussed the personal level
which
is sort of a human level and i think
that that is
why we all should be in this i mean the
ability that bitcoin has to change
individual lives is
staggering um but there's also a
geopolitical element yeah and
you know regardless of who's running
afghanistan
it is broken
that
you know almost all of the country's
savings is in new york whether it be in
treasuries cash gold other instruments
that's broken i mean that's that's like
a dependency system and you know i spoke
to roya about this and
you know obviously she's no fan of the
taliban but
you know she does hope that one day her
country can actually be independent
right
you know i think no afghan wants
all of their country's money to be in
new york city like that doesn't make any
sense and like if you actually think
about and look at
the the how the war went over these 20
years
a staggering amount of the money that
was invested let's say in afghanistan i
mean you know you know the numbers
there's more than a trillion spent on
the war in total but but there was about
170 billion spent
uh in what we might call investing in
afghanistan so like infrastructure
programs etc etc the crazy part is
something like 80 to 90 percent of that
went back into the united states so it
was paid to like american contractors
etc etc so very little of that that
really big number that you see that like
oh we you know this is what it cost um
very little of that trickled down into
afghan society and was absorbed by local
institutions if anything anything you
know most of what was absorbed locally
was absorbed by local thieves i mean if
you think ashraf ghani i mean the the
head the leader of afghanistan who just
escaped i mean he allegedly had 170
million dollars in suitcases there's a
video you can watch him when he's
getting on the aircraft to leave
you know there's like a bunch of
suitcases
and allegedly he stole a bunch of money
from the country and you know this is a
this is this guy wrote a book on fixing
failed states and he went you know he's
taught at all these elite universities
united states these guys are you know
professional grifters i mean at the end
of the day um and and he's out of there
now and
you know at the end of the day like
a lot of that money that we that
american taxpayers spent a lot of that
money that that we went into debt for
um you know is wasted or went you know
into corruption
and i i think that like afghans know
this and they would prefer a different
system where they could be a little more
independent and and certainly bitcoin
helps there right so if you have a
future afghanistan that's
you know instead of taking i mean right
now afghanistan can't even take the debt
from the imf the imf was supposed to
give it like 400 million
450 million dollars of what are called
sdrs
which are like credits that basically
afghanistan could then like swap for
hard currency
they can't the obviously the taliban
can't even get those because the bite
administration doesn't want them to have
any money right
so i mean
yes i understand it from a realist
foreign policy perspective but it's also
kind of like economic terrorism on the
people like like what's going to happen
is they're basically strangling that the
the afghan economy right um and i get it
i they don't like the taliban but like
guess who's going to pay the price not
the taliban like they have plenty of you
know opium fields like they'll be okay
the people will struggle right so when
we have bitcoin you can see it as this
tool again to help on the individual
level it can also help on that
international level like these countries
in the developing world they're going to
be able to instead of again
instead of taking out these loans from
the imf which if they don't pay back
then they have to do like structural
reforms and you know maybe get
overthrown in a coup for like having
passed austerity measures um no they can
like harness their energy in their
country and mine bitcoin or they can do
bitcoin energy bonds like el salvador is
doing um i think there's a lot of ways
that bitcoin can help at the
geopolitical level um and at the end of
the day i hope a lot of these developing
countries in the future don't have to
have all their all their savings in in
new york they can they can have it at
home you know
two other places that i know that you
spend a lot of time thinking about
writing about or learning is cuba and
nigeria
both two different situations maybe talk
a little bit about cuba first then we
talk about nigeria just in terms of uh
during this kind of uh revolution or
protest that's going on in cuba uh
obviously there tends to be uh kind of a
bitcoin movement movement that goes
along with it so what's going on in cuba
yeah well i mean obviously to us but but
most people don't don't see
what's happening with bitcoin in cuba
i i wrote a kind of a deep dive into
what i would call bitcoins
or rather cuba's peaceful bitcoin
revolution for bitcoin magazine uh two
weeks ago
and i think it's important to note that
like cubans are going through the
hardest time
economically that they've gone through
since the early 90s uh
ever since
fidel and che created modern cuba
in 59
they became incredibly dependent on the
soviet union
for everything i mean they basically
exported all their sugar there soviets
bought the sugar at a higher than market
price uh really the soviets kind of kept
cuba alive so when the soviet union fell
cuba went into something called the
special period in the early 90s where
they you know they just were sort of
strangled economically they didn't have
any way of generating money and the peso
collapsed their currency went from being
like five to a dollar to like 150 to a
dollar
um and people started like using dollars
actually there was like a dollarization
that happened in cuba similar to what's
happening in venezuela now
um and to prevent that from like really
taking over because obviously that's
like the enemy's currency if you're
fidel right you don't want people using
american money
he created a fake dollar called the cuc
or the convertible peso in 94.
um and this was this has been you know
was used heavily until earlier this year
and what ended up happening was like the
greatest rug pull of all time because
between 94 and 2004
cubans used dollars they used these like
cucs they used pesos um and it was kind
of all floating and and cubans owned
dollars like cubans had dollars at home
they had dollars in bank accounts in
cuba like us dollars right in 2004 the
government came out and said no no no
more dollars so they took all the
dollars and they replaced them with
these fake dollars so you what you saw
is like the the cuban people holding the
hard currency the actual usd all of a
sudden the government was holding it and
they were holding these
a bag of this you know fake dollars
which were just phased out right earlier
this year so this is like a giant rug
pull where the government is like
stealing time and energy from the people
it's really tragic so now they have a
new scheme called the mlc which is even
crazier because
essentially in cuba there's like
different kinds of stores right you have
your like rations like bottom barrel
kind of essentials that the government
kind of hands out which are not enough
to live off of at all so you have to
actually go buy stuff with money in
stores and the stores today that that
have good stuff only accept something
called an mlc
now an mlc is like almost like a gift
card account you have to top it up but
get this you can't top it up with pesos
so most people in cuba they work for the
state they make pesos or their pension
is paid out in pesos so they have to go
to the black market and exchange their
pesos for mlc
at a at the black market rate and the
government says the rates one to 24 uh
in terms of uh a dollar to peso on the
street it's 1-70 right so the
government's just stealing from the
people and they're forcing them to
actually get their family abroad to top
up their mlc account with pounds or
euros or you know pay you know brazilian
currency etc
and that's the only way you can buy
stuff at stores to survive you need like
an air conditioner if you need good food
meat whatever you gotta you gotta use
mlc so this is another rug pull where
the government is basically paying its
workers in in collapsing pesos but
collecting hard currency from abroad and
and this there's just so much injustice
in this and yes the united states
embargo is a big part of the problem 100
really at the end of the day it's like
the dictatorship and and this economic
kind of exploitation system they have i
mean think about it cuba's biggest
export
is is is essentially indentured
servitude of medical personnel that
literally their biggest export it's like
11 billion dollars a year is sending
nurses and doctors to countries abroad
and the state takes 75 percent of their
wages
the second biggest export is you know
either tourism or sugar etc but like
this is a state built on exploitation
and people have had enough of it and
what's interesting is in my interviews
with cubans all over the island
it's not just dissidents or you know
pro-democracy opposition folks who are
using bitcoin it's also the communists
this is we call this the money of
enemies i mean anybody can use it so you
have people who are hardcore communists
who believe in the revolution and all
this stuff they're using bitcoin and
then of course you have all the you know
people who are more like uh screw the
government they're using bitcoin too um
but it it's it's just remarkable to see
and it is a microcosm of what you're
seeing all across the world today and
people are fed up with the money system
it doesn't work it's essentially a scam
in many places um and they're opting
into something that's not a scam they're
opting into something that's like hard
money that's going to be there for them
in the future
when you think about a place like
nigeria is it a lot of the same elements
of what's happening in cuba or is there
complete
difference in that the government is
different uh and also demographically
there's a bunch of young people with uh
smartphone penetration and that's why it
ends up being so popular for bitcoin
like what what is the difference that
you see as to why nigeria seems to be so
uh embracing of bitcoin yeah i mean at
first you would think oh there's nothing
you know
they have no similarities one is a small
communist uh island that's largely cut
off from the outside world and
has a
centrally planned economy and the other
is a vibrant you know
uh
oil-rich um you know state that's the
largest country in africa with
incredible dynamic you know young
population and
all this stuff and you would look at the
two and you would say oh there's there's
no similarity so they have a big
similarity though the money's broken
right and it may be broken in different
ways um but in nigeria you've got 15
inflation you've got 20 30 food
inflation
um you have a population that doesn't
trust the government uh you have a
government that steals from the people
even with these like uh kind of like
special police units they go around
robbing people uh you have a government
that has almost total immunity i mean
you know horrible things happen and no
one goes to prison um and again people
are opting out right so
it's similar in that way you know the
money system's broken people are opting
out into bitcoin right
and in nigeria you're seeing kind of
like it's kind of like one of the
capitals of bitcoin in the world today
is la is you know it's lagos i mean it's
nigeria is people are innovating so
rapidly
um yes only about half of nigerians have
sort of
constant internet access um but but uh
but millions of nigerians are using
bitcoin i mean if you even just look at
one exchange alone packs full
they have close to two million users
in nigeria two million and that's just
one platform out of many right there's
also tons of nigerian built platforms
like whether it be buy coins or bitnob
etc so you're seeing an explosion of
innovation
and of people using uh bitcoin there for
for some of the same reasons you know as
you might in cuba um
again in cuba it's really hard to send
remittance right if you live in the
united states the us government has
passed laws preventing you from the us
from sending money to cuba that's on the
us's side that's not like the cash
that's not the fault of the cash draws
right
so what do people do i mean they might
pay a mule to like literally take they
might wire cash to panama and then pay
somebody to get an airplane to go to
cuba um they might wire money to spain
or canada and have that person top up
someone's mlc account
all this stuff is expensive time
consuming i mean it's just a huge
bureaucratic hassle so that's why
they're just bitcoin boom right there
direct instantly you know if you use
something like the moon wallet or the
blue wallet you can use lightning you're
sending 50 100 a thousand dollars for a
couple satoshi's for literally free
essentially and it's instant right
um
and similar to nigeria like nigerians
are largely cut off from from the
outside world in many ways um and and
yet bitcoin is a great connector like
the friends of mine made a an app called
send cash and it allows anyone in the
world to send
value
on an app
uh with bitcoin to any bank account in
nigeria and it settles in minutes i mean
with no fee right if you look at cent
cash africa that's an incredible
innovation on par with what jack mullers
and striker doing right um so you're
seeing
people fight their way out and and and
again cuba afghanistan nigeria three
countries that all have a pretty pretty
strong dependence on remittances nigeria
is also four or five percent for a much
larger country obviously so you're
talking billions of dollars
um but some of these countries pump like
i mean you think about
there are smaller island countries uh
there are countries throughout west
africa south asia some of these
countries are 30 i mean 20 you know el
salvador is 20 25 dependent on
remittances so you have a lot of the
developing world where like a really
large percentage of the gdp of basically
the economic engine of the country runs
on money being sent home and you look at
the average remittance the average
remittance you know has a fee of
you know something like six seven eight
percent that's being taken by middlemen
it takes a couple days it could get
frozen
um that's that's in the past man that's
in the rearview mirror hopefully for a
lot of people because as you as you held
the funeral for western union like these
these these guys are just they're the
next blockbuster i mean they're gonna go
in the trash bin of history because we
have a better technology now that's
gonna do so
so much better for people it's gonna
help them save their time and energy
more effectively and and it's gonna
really lift a lot of people up
i could not agree more obviously uh i've
got my two brothers here with me uh you
guys got any questions yeah i'll go
first uh alex thanks for doing this
really appreciate you uh coming on big
fan of uh everything you guys are doing
i guess my question would be just around
um
so the human rights foundation like how
has what you guys are focusing on on a
daily basis changed over the last few
years
and uh off of that how can the bitcoin
community help support what you guys are
doing uh and amplify your message
yeah well i mean the world has
kind of stagnated in terms of democratic
progress in the last 15 years you
obviously you had this incredible
historic you know series of waves of
democracy
uh in the in the in the 70s and the 80s
and the 90s i mean not that long ago
europe was was there was dictatorships
all over europe greece portugal spain um
then you obviously had to follow the
soviet union you had open societies pop
up all over eastern europe you had
a lot of elections you had a lot of
uh good good good reforms like amazing
progress for people
all over the world and then that kind of
like
slowed down and it actually stopped kind
of uh in the last 15 years and
what we've seen in our work is is large
countries like thailand
uh the philippines bangladesh turkey
take really big steps backwards in terms
of human rights so the the the the need
for the work of
groups like ours i think is more
important than ever um you're seeing a
lot of backsliding and you're also
seeing governments
figure out how to use technology to
repress people um i i think that most
technology is is honestly unfortunately
uh kind of authoritarian if you think
about things like big data analysis ai
uh this idea of central bank digital
currencies this idea of social credit
this idea of
everything going digital and making it
easier for the state to do things like
that's not great for the individual so
we're up we're up in a difficult time
uh our work has changed
again to to adapt to this idea of wow
we're really like you know in a
defensive position right now but also
that technology is at the heart of
everything i mean if you think about
what's happening in
whether it be xinjiang with you know the
persecution of millions of uyghurs i
mean it's all done in a high-tech police
state
whether you think about uh the
surveillance of activists like uh jamal
khashoggi who was a saudi journalist who
was
murdered by the saudi government in in a
grizzly affair in istanbul my
organization we made a movie about that
called the dissident that i would urge
you to check out it's done by brian
fogle who also did icarus about the
olympic doping scandal in russia and the
cycling team
um so check out the dissident you'll
learn a lot about our work there
um we you know we we we're out there to
educate people on why freedom matters
and why dictatorship and
authoritarianism is is not good for
humans and
and we're out there to like basically
shine a light on voices that are that
are making a difference and
and we're out there to show you how you
can help and i just think over the last
five years especially for me personally
i've just seen how relevant bitcoin is
to all of this to this whole mission
because at the end of the day like we
can do a lot of virtue signaling like we
can go on twitter and we can
you know i did a big piece on palestine
recently actually and
a lot of people are happy to like tweet
about you know free palestine or help
the palestinians okay fine that's not
actually doing anything like how are you
actually gonna help somebody who lives
in gaza right well you can actually
empower them today by teaching them
about bitcoin and onboarding them and
helping them you know convert
their shekels or whatever currency
they're using to bitcoin that can allow
them to connect to their family abroad
and have freedom so i think it's really
interesting because because bitcoin in
many ways is kind of like the it's kind
of like the upper upper
you know the implementation of human
rights activism uh and i'm not it's not
to say i'm not proud of everything else
that we do all the time i think it's
vital but bitcoins really like the you
know the actual integration or like the
instantiation of um
a lot of the like advocacy or activism
you see out there and of like ra ra we
should we should help these people um
and then you read something in the
newspaper oh we should help these people
in this country and then you go back to
what you're doing no no you can actually
help them right now we just have to like
teach them about this powerful freedom
technology so in that sense i'm more
excited than ever because i think the
impact we can make especially now
when we know that this technology is so
young and it's going to take over the
world over the coming decade the impact
we can have today by educating and
informing activists about it is just
staggering to think about
john what questions you got yeah alex
thanks for doing this thanks for all the
work you do as well um i know it's very
important but i'm interested because you
were just talking about how bitcoin is
like that freedom power technology um
and in gaza how you can help them by
having them convert their money into um
bitcoin but how do you think about the
education gap in getting those people
actually educated besides outside of
just like me here in the u.s thinking
about family and friends
well
i think there's two parts to this one is
that like
bitcoin's kind of fine like it's weird
it's like this organic thing that just
grows and it's not going to be stopped
regardless of what we do or not do
um
but on the other hand people aren't
going to be fine right so i'm less
worried about bitcoin i think bitcoin is
going to
i mean if you look at every day there's
more and more institutions adopting it i
mean i mean yesterday we had sub stack
we had the second largest uh home lender
in america we had iran reverse bitcoin
mining we had um el salvador installing
bitcoin machines you know atms all over
the country like that
the milestones are turning into a blur
like it's like the beginning of this
hyper bitcoinization thing that that we
all you know thought may happen
um so i think bitcoin's fine
but i think people need our help right
so again
you know i i want to do what i can do to
help like the the leaders of the human
rights activist movements around the
world and that's what we do through our
oslo freedom forum series we have a
great conference happening in miami on
october 4 and 5 where we have
really prominent human rights activists
we have alexei navalny giving a speech
that he's going to smuggle out of prison
we have the
opposition leader of belarus we have the
secretary general of amnesty
international we have a lot of amazing
speakers on the human rights side and
we're also going to be running a bitcoin
academy so my hope is to like
put this power into the hands of
activists who can then in like this kind
of trickle-down sense educate the rest
of the movement in their countries so
that's what i want to do through the
human rights foundation um but you know
i think that everybody
can start local you know with their own
family and friends and just
you know you gotta
give them some perspective like i wrote
this piece that might be helpful called
check your financial privilege which i
think is important because
so many people in the west are
comfortable with their money like
they're not dealing with what afghans or
cubans or palestinians are dealing with
it's like they have we have venmo
whatever it's cool like the dollar's
fine like it inflates a little bit it's
not a big deal whatever um i can just i
have a 401k
and i i you know i can do a swipe i have
apple pay all these things like cubans
have none of those things right so
there's this great disparity um
and even a lot of americans don't have
those things like tons of americans are
underbanked like you know or unbanked
and
a lot of communities that are that are
financially discriminated against i mean
i think the work of isaiah jackson is
really key in this area obviously you
guys have had him on and continue to
work with him um so it's really a global
conversation
um but i do think that that that
showing the stories of people struggling
around the world and how they're finding
some hope in bitcoin it is helpful in
convincing people who are skeptical like
what do they say to that i mean there's
no retort i mean you can be some snide
journalist or you know investor and
you're like oh bitcoins like a scam or
whatever and it's like oh really well
like
you know that is really privileged of
you to say that and and um you know
you know why don't you try living on the
sudanese pound for three months and then
get back to me about how bitcoin's
useless like if these people would just
get out of their bubble and and put
themselves in somebody else's shoes for
three days i mean they would never
complain to us about bitcoin ever again
so it's just a matter of like helping
them understand that like we had a
central banker yesterday nil pishkari
from the the minneapolis fed
he's out there talking about how
he doesn't see how cryptocurrency is
anything but a scam and it's like man
like how
how
you know how sheltered is he man that is
just so crazy to think about when there
are people in his own in his own state
in minneapolis who are who are earning
and and saving and really like lifting
themselves up with bitcoin forget cuba
or palestine there are people in
downtown minneapolis doing that so i
think it's just a matter of time with
these people and we want to be open and
helpful and we want to we want to share
this educational material with them i
think that's that's quite important if
people want to support what we're doing
at hrf um you know we're doing a couple
things uh we're doing a lot of public
advocacy like this right uh we're doing
hands-on trainings like i mentioned to
you all at our events at through the
oslo freedom forum and then we and then
we also have a dev fund where we collect
money from donors and then we we give it
to
uh bitcoin devs who are working on open
source privacy technology open source
wallet technology around the world we've
done a lot of things i'm proud of you
know
sponsoring moon wallet sponsoring
spectre helping people run nodes helping
people use lightning we have a lot of
gifts coming in the next couple weeks we
have a big announcement i'm really
excited about um
every quarter we give we give funding
out
so you know you want to support us you
can check out ahref.org
btc if you want to donate in bitcoin uh
or just if you wanted to learn about it
go to ahref.org go to the oslo freedom
forum i would be really grateful to to
get feedback from people and
hear how you want to contribute i think
the cool part is now that we live in
this bitcoin world
you can make a difference so immediately
you know anywhere you want
alex it goes without saying that uh i my
brothers etc all uh really appreciate
the work you guys are doing
it's just you know it's one of these
situations where i think on the internet
uh everyone likes to yell and scream and
act like idiots but the
gravity of the situation when you
understand how much people are hurting
um how bad uh some people are um in
terms of the situation that they're in
and the help that they need uh i wish
that there was a hundred organizations
like you all but but you guys are
continuing to kind of push forward and
really make a
material impact in the world which uh
you know is um
just great to see and so anyone who's
watching this who uh is interested in
this stuff or wants to learn more highly
highly highly suggest going to hrf.org
or hrf or dot org slash btc
is uh is uh where you can see that
bitcoin developers fund um
uh if anyone remembers the bitcoin pizza
uh we actually took uh the profits from
that and donated it there um and we've
got some other stuff that we'll be doing
in the future uh so um you know
basically if you want to help that that
is probably one of the best places you
can go but uh i appreciate you coming on
here and just talking about kind of the
the reality of the situation because i
think it's easy for most people to see
bitcoin and the price charts and yelling
scream on the internet and you know
laser eyes and everything is fun but uh
obviously this uh this technology is
really really powerful and can help a
lot of people so hopefully we can
continue to uh to kind of push that
forward over time
yeah thanks for having me on and just
one thing to take away to remember is
that before bitcoin uh
you know every fiat currency or or every
digital currency that ever had existed
the rules about the money were
controlled by a small group of people
whether that be bureaucrats a currency
board a fed a central bank or even a
company you know if you're a company
making your own currency or issuing your
own credit system
and satoshi gave us a new way forward
satoshi invented a digital currency
where the money rules aren't controlled
by a small group of people they're
actually controlled by you so bitcoin
users
you decide what implementation of the
protocol you want to run
and you decide whether or not there
should be 21 million and all the bitcoin
users are united in a particular way uh
that that defends the protocol and that
that keeps the money system uh the way
it is where it's transparent and open
and i i think that's important to
to point out uh today
and i'm i'm grateful to live in a world
with bitcoin
if we didn't have bitcoin again all
currencies around the world would be
subject to change by a small group of
people and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and that's just the way it is
i mean look there's a lot of nice people
out there i'm not doubting people's
intentions but at the end of the day
power corrupts and and people you know
people do find ways to um
to exploit and and even if you're a
someone who goes into the central
banking world and you feel like you're
going to make a difference and help
people
um
at the end of the day all you're doing
is doing your best right and you're
going to tweak things you're going to
move things around you're going to do
your best and the same goes for any
currency project that has a small group
of people who decide the monetary
issuance and at the end of the day
bitcoin's different and i'm so glad it
exists as just like an escape
and as a new foundation for a new system
so i look forward to being on this
journey with you guys uh as we as we
enter this next decade thanks so much
for having me on
hrf.org
btc or go follow alex at gladsteen on
twitter thank you so much my friend we
will uh we will definitely be doing this
again so keep up the good work and we'll
talk soon thanks pomp thanks guys thanks
alex
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]